yeah no those were uh i i made a i'm
gonna show you those are the good old
days everything's
it's just different now it's different
it's on steroids it's all stairs there's
no like room it's crazy because we were
just talking um
i was just having some conversations
with with a good friend of mine about uh
who who used to have a residency in
vegas not too long ago like 2017 2016
and some of the nights that we may or
may not have had
in vegas that we are like yo that was
like four or five years ago and the [ __ ]
that we were doing back then we could
never do
in today's world
just because of the [ __ ] social media
aspect and how much
more magnified everything is
that's not true
you can you just can't go on
social media look at it
see i
i had got off social media for like a
year and a half
and i just focused on myself
because it was leading to depression i
hadn't said this in a lot of interviews
before i was making comparisons i was
comparing other people's highlight reel
to my real life right and the comparison
is the killer of all joy
so i wasn't finding my gratitude
but once i got off
instagram
for like the first
i think like the first week i used to go
to my phone and look and check cause i
and i was like damn
i'm addicted
that's an addiction man i'm addicted to
going look and it's the same pictures
over and over again most people's first
thing they do when they wake up grab
their phone and open up ig yeah i can't
do that because they take my energy from
me i got to get up and go straight and
work out i can't talk to nobody you
won't touch your phone until you're done
working out well i got one phone that
don't have no apps on it it got all my
music and stuff on there that's my gem
phone but that's my most important phone
my little smartphone my other phones i
got all that [ __ ] on up but when i go to
sleep i cut my phones on airplane mode
because i read
that the transmission from the phone
they mess up your melatonin cycles
and you don't get the rest that you're
supposed to get
so you're not gonna have the energy that
you're supposed to have the next day so
i put my phones on airplane mode
and then
sometimes i forget they on airplane mode
and then you'll be running around all
day you'll be like man damn i'm tripping
quite whatever i missed it
anything i missed it wasn't meant for me
because anything that's meant for me it
ain't gonna miss me
so anything lost could be found again
except for time wasted i didn't waste
time today
i didn't get on the phone and talk
because if i get on the phone or talk
before i go to the gym i ain't even
gonna work out
and we ain't talking about nothing cause
you ain't did nothing but the same [ __ ]
that you do every day
you ain't did nothing spectacular like
we ain't doing nothing spectacular i'm
not doing nothing spectacular i do the
same thing every day but this is what
makes me feel good
yeah i've heard that a lot of uh
billionaires millionaires ceos that's
they have that morning routine where you
don't touch your phone until you do
something
productive
whether it's have breakfast my best
coffee come when i'm working up
my best thoughts it's something about
getting up early in the morning how
early
i'm up early maybe three a.m
when i'm about to go to bed then maybe
like 7 p.m 8 p.m if i'm like today i'm
gonna be finished at like six
so i'll probably get in about eight
wow
that's early but i'm gonna take me a hot
bear
with the salt i got my little
my little woo-wop
and i'm gonna let my whole body relax
then i'm gonna lay down and go to sleep
and get rich so i can get up and go to
the gym and egg bed